[Music]
you're not a fan of drinking but when
she does
what's your about that time yeah well
one time we were in Milan one they were
and let me tell you I drank some vino
yeah we call it we call it I call it
wine in this country you had some vino
it goes with the food it's the whole
thing I was like whatever it was
breakfast yes it was a very small like
Italian Eve situation and I was like I'm
gonna drink some wine and so I had like
turn it to a completely different person
oh really
like I was literally will ferrell from
anchorman yet you're a sexy woman I'm
trying to go feral you grew a moustache
just like a red suit like flowered out
of my body was like Berlin buco so
that's the person you I have video and I
don't remember any of it we were in the
back of a cab - I'm sure he remember
that guy doesn't know we were saying
what what what about what about you who
do you become I think I become don't
have become classier when I know person
in the world
let's go to the Art Museum chao-li I
can't see straight I turn into Julie
Andrews idea I sing a little bit but I
also know that's not the classy British
accent chimney sweep no it's pretty
amazing because I took it into a dude
and she turns into like a fancy lady
who's completely wasted and you're not
classier by the way so you become a very
uninhibited woman and you become a very
sophisticated man interesting People's
Choice Lawrence drink before you do it
we're thinking about it what do you guys
say ward yeah a drink beforehand rather
see Julie enters in Ron Burgundy's
because I you should drink thank a lot
before you go out it's my advice to its
CBS they're very loose about that stuff